hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be explaining
why now in 2022 it is nearly impossible
to save a deposit to buy a house i've
recently been reading so many articles
and in so many books where authors and
influencers are telling people to cancel
netflix
and stop drinking starbucks every day
and instead
save that and then buy an investment
property and whilst that sounds like
good advice i think it's actually
terrible advice especially if you're
buying an investment property because
how many cups of coffee are you gonna
have to save
you need 25 deposit and the average
house
right now in the uk is worth 276 000
pounds
so if you're gonna need 25 of 276 000
pounds that's a lot that's like over 50
000 pounds
plus you have to pay stamp duty
that's going to be probably around about
another 10 000 pounds plus your legals
your mortgage fees so realistically just
to buy an average house in the uk right
now
you're going to need around 60 70 000
pounds catch this the average salary in
the uk
is around about 25 000 pounds a year
well
that's about 2 000 pounds a month
and that doesn't take into account your
tax that you have to pay
so if you're if your take home is let's
say 1500 1600 pounds a month
well the average rent
right now in the uk is 1 000 pounds a
month
so if you're getting paid fifteen
hundred two thousand pounds a month
your rent has taken the majority of your
wage
then you've gotta pay your gas electric
council tax broadband and and you've
gotta eat
so how is it possible to save enough
money to actually buy a property and put
down a deposit and the answer is it
isn't it's getting harder and harder and
harder and the reason is is because
everything's going up and up and up
house prices are going up on average
every 10 years they're doubling in value
and people always go oh they're not
going to do that in the next 10 and what
happens they do so house prices are
going up and up and up
rents are going up and up and up energy
prices are about to go up by 40 percent
petrol is going up everything's
increasing the only thing that's not
increasing and hasn't done particularly
for years and years is
wages
so if you're in the mindset of i'm going
to save up a deposit from my wages and
buy an investment property then you're
going to really really struggle and i
know this video might seem a bit
negative but i'm just going to hit you
with the truth and i'm going to tell you
how it is right now in 2022 and then i'm
gonna talk to you about the solution by
the way if you enjoy my content if you
enjoy my channel please do me a massive
favor and hit like let's say you're
making two three thousand pounds a month
you're making decent-ish okay money and
you live quite frugally and you're not
spending on netflix and you're not
spending on starbucks realistically if
you're saving the average person saving
500 pounds a month
that's pretty good 500 a month pretty
impressive
if you need to save up 50 60 000 pounds
to buy a property how long is that going
to take just do the maths okay that's
going to take about 10 years
to buy
a below average property investment 10
years and here's the thing right if you
save up 500 pounds a month for 10 years
and you've got say 50 60 grand by the
time you've got that money
house prices are probably going to have
doubled so you're going to be like oh
i've spent 10 years saving all this
money and i'm now only halfway there
another 10 years
it's just absolutely ludicrous to think
that saving money every month and being
frugal is going to help you be able to
become a property investor and become
wealthy let's say okay hypothetically
that you're paid really well let's say
you're making five ten grand a month and
you're in a really good job you're
working 50 60 70 hours a week and you're
able to save half of your salary let's
say you're able to get 60 grand within
just a few years okay great
what what's gonna happen then you'll buy
a house let's say you buy a house for
two hundred thousand pounds
and you put down fifty thousand pounds
deposit plus stamp duty tax legals
another ten 000 pounds so 60 grand is
down you now own a house let's say you
rent that house out and you rent it out
for a thousand pounds a month well
you're gonna have to pay your mortgage
interest payments
that's probably going to come to around
about four or five hundred pounds so
half of your rent is gone
then you're gonna have to pay
management you're gonna have to pay
maintenance so how much profit are you
gonna be left
from that investment property probably
two or three hundred pounds a month
so
you've managed to finally buy a property
investment whoopee do all the hard work
and the labor and the blood and the
sweat and the tears and you own a
property investment and you were making
five grand a month but now you're making
five thousand
and two hundred and fifty pounds
how many times are you going to need to
do that before you become financially
free how many decades is it going to
take
to become financially free by saving and
investing and the answer is it's going
to take more than a lifetime so that's
why i believe that saving up to invest
in property and saving up to buy houses
is actually a really bad way to try and
become financially free so what is the
solution well the solution is twofold
number one instead of trying to save
money
you need to think about how you can make
more money
instead of instead of thinking how can i
save my 2 000 pounds by canceling
netflix and being frugal you need to be
thinking instead of making 2 000 pounds
a month how can i make 20 000 pounds a
month and how can i do that
now this year
and there's many ways you can do that
through business through property a way
that i did when i started out
was i learned how to package and sell
deals this is called deal sourcing the
average deal sourcer and i've trained
thousands of people to do this
the average deal sourcer makes between
two and five thousand pounds per
deal now you're not having to buy
anything you're not investing in
anything you're just finding a deal
sourcing a deal and passing it on to an
investor making two to five thousand
pounds a month i mean if you can do a
deal like that once a week
suddenly you're in a situation whereby
you can save deposits because instead of
focusing on saving your two grand salary
you're thinking how can i make more
money the other way is rather than
thinking about i have to own properties
i have to buy properties
how's about thinking
all the businesses in the world that are
the most successful rather than owning
things
they focus on controlling things uber
don't own their cars
amazon doesn't own most of its stock
airbnb don't own their hotels but they
act as a middleman they're running a
business where they're getting paid to
have control
and something that you can do which is
called rent to rent
and many people think rent to rent is
illegal or is it subletting it's
completely not in fact this is the
business model that premiere in do
premiere in don't own their hotels
premier inn
rent the building off of the off of the
owner and then they then run it as a
business
and make money
by running it as a hotel and renting it
out for a higher amount guess what you
can do the exact same thing too but
instead of renting a massive hotel
building you can rent a small studio
apartment off of a landlord with the
correct contracts with the correct
permissions in place and then you can
rent that apartment that studio
apartment on booking.com on airbnb
pay the landlord i mean there was there
was a couple called anna and renato and
i met anna and renato a few months ago
and they were working really hard in
their jobs and they they didn't have
enough money to stop buying properties
they understood that saving money to
invest in property was not smart so they
learned about rent to rent and they
rented a small
apartment in aylesbury for 750 pounds a
month with the agreement from the
landlord that they wouldn't live there
they'd put the property on airbnb and
booking.com and have shortstay guests
they're paying the landlord 750
they're renting it out for 2 000 pounds
a month
after all their costs they're left with
750 pounds a month clean profit
so they're making 750 a month clean
profit from one apartment that they
don't own that cost them about 1500
pounds
to get set up
would you rather be the guy who saves 15
years and buys the house and makes 250
pounds a month
or the guy or girl that
rents a property on a rent-to-rent basis
and makes 750 pounds profit puts down
1500 pounds to secure the deal and gets
the keys immediately and starts making
the cash flow now i know which person
i'd rather be i'd rather be person b
so instead of thinking about being
frugal and saving money think about
making more money by having a business
maybe deal sourcing instead of thinking
about owning properties maybe think
about controlling properties and then
when you become financially free and
able to leave your job and are making
good cash flow
then go get rich then go build an empire
then go and create generational wealth
for your family so i hope this video has
helped and made you think a little bit
differently around probably if you want
to even see the apartment that anna and
renato are using as their service
department and making 750 pounds a month
right here check it out go see it if you
want to join me at one of my property
investors crash course events where i
can train you in these strategies then
click right here i'd love to meet you
i'd love to help you i'd love to help
you become financially free this year
through being a property entrepreneur
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]